네 오늘은 새로운 AI 대장주가 될 수도 있는
넥스트 엔비디아가 될 수도 있는
그런 회사가 있는 것 같아서
한번 얘기를 해보려고 하고요
당연한 얘기겠지만
매수 매도에 대한 추천 아니다라는 거 말씀드리고
자 오늘 주인공은 인텔입니다
인텔이고
요즘에 한국인들이 정말 많이 매수를 하고 있어요
그래서 이 인텔이 왜 이렇게 기대를 받고 있는지
또 앞으로 전망은 어떨지 한번
제가 장점과 단점, 기대되는 부분과
리스크적인 부분들을 다 같이 좀 얘기를 해보려고 하고요
인텔이 최근에 주목받은 이유는 바로 이 부분입니다
이게 한 4월부터 이런 얘기가 솔솔 나왔어요
AI 데이터 센터에서도 이제 점점 CPU가 필요해진다
이런 얘기들이 나왔습니다
전통적인 언어모델을 돌릴 때는
GPU만 많이 있어도 됐는데
이제 시간이 흐르고 보니까
이 에이전틱 AI에서는
아 CPU랑 GPU랑 거의 비슷한 비율로 필요한 것 같다
이런 거를 트렌드포스 같은 시장 조사를 하는 기간이니까요
이런 데서 발간을 했고요
또 그 외에도 모건 스탠리에서도
복잡한 작업을 하면 할수록
CPU의 비중이 높아진다
이런 얘기를 하고 있습니다
혹시 모르실까봐 CPU랑 GPU
아주 간단하게만 설명을 드리면
CPU는 여러 가지를 다재다능하게 잘하는
그런 올라운드 플레이어 같은 친구다라고 볼 수가 있겠고요
GPU는 정말 극단적으로 말하면
행렬 계산만 잘해
아주 단순한
몇 가지 연산을 아주 빠르게 할 수 있는 특성이 있습니다
그러니까 서로 좀 능력치가 다르다
굳이 말하자면
올라운드 플레이어와 한쪽 능력만
아주 발달한 그런 친구가 GPU다
이렇게 구분을 하시면 될 것 같아요
자 그런데 전통적인 언어모델
그러니까 질문을 하고 답변만 받을 때는
인공지능이 어떤 생각을 하기 위해서
AI 행렬 계산할 일이 엄청나게 많았는데
이 에이전틱 AI라는 게
뭐 이따가 뒤에서도 말하겠지만
유저가 원하는 일을
처리를 하는 거거든요
이 에이전트들이
그러면 유저가 원하는 일들이
결국에 컴퓨터를 다루는 일들이기 때문에
이제는 복잡한 사고를 할 수 있는
CPU가 많이 필요해진다라는 그런 관점이고
인텔이나 ARM이나 AMD 같은
CPU 3대장 회사라고 할 수 있는데
이런 회사들이 주가가 지난 한 달 동안에
정말 대폭등을 했습니다
근데 이게 진짜인지 아닌지를
한번 보자라는 관점이고
그중에서도 가장 지난 한 달간 많이 오른 게
인텔이기 때문에
그럼 시장은 어떻게 보면
인텔이 대장이라고 생각하고
하는 거 같은데
인텔이 과연 그 대장주에
자격이 있는지를 좀 볼 건데요
그 전에 이런 생각도 좀 들더라고요
자 어떤 생각이 좀 들었냐면
만약에 아까 제가 보여드린 리포트에서도
CPU와 GPU가 1대1로 필요하다
이런 얘기들이 많잖아요
그러면은 진짜 이거 좀 초딩적인 생각인데
사실 뭐 주식이라는 게 다 그렇습니다
초딩적인 생각으로는
CPU 3총사 시가총액 다 합치면
엔비디아 C총 정도는 되어야 되는 거 아니냐
왜냐면 CPU랑 GPU랑 1대1로 필요하다고 하니깐
그런 관점에서도 우리가 아주 단순하게
시장을 좀 볼 필요도 있을 것 같은데
그런 관점에서 보잖아요
그러면 상당히 CPU 업체들이 매력적으로 보이는
부분들이 분명히 있습니다
엔비디아의 시가총액은 5트릴리언 달러인데
CPU의 3대장 회사들을 다 합쳐봤자
1.5트릴리언 달러밖에 안 되거든요
그러니까 한 3배 더 작으니까
매력적이다 이렇게 생각할 수도 있을 것 같아요
그리고 에이전틱 AI에 대해서도
조금만 더 첨언을 좀 해 보자면
이렇게 생각을 하고
기존의 언어모델 그냥 내가 물어보면 답변만 했는데
에이전틱 AI부터는 AI가 주도적으로 컴퓨터를 사용해서
내가 시키는 일들을 합니다
내가 시키는 일이라는 게 뭐냐
이번 달에 내가 어디에 지출했는지 엑셀 파일로 정리해
이런 식으로 일을 시킬 수 있겠죠
그러면 나의 에이전트들은 내 컴퓨터를 직접 열어서
뭐 내가 신한카드 내가 신한카드를 많이 써
신한카드 사이트 들어가서 나의 구매내역을 확인하고
또 그 구매내역을 엑셀로 다운 받아가지고
그 엑셀 파일을 열어서
열고 컨트롤 C 컨트롤 V 해서
나의 가계부 엑셀 파일에다가 그 부분을 복사해서 붙인다든가
아니면 조금 수정을 해야 되면 수정을 해야 한다거나
이런 것들을 정말 마치 사람이 컴퓨터를 다뤄서 해야 할 것 같은 일을
주도적으로 아주 긴 시간 동안 하는 그런 AI를 에이전틱 AI라고 합니다
왜 이런 게 가능해졌느냐
쉽게 말해서 언어 모델들이 똑똑해져서
인공지능 모델들이 똑똑해졌기 때문에
그때 그 순간 순간에 상황 판단을 하면서
내가 시키는 일을 한다는 거죠
내가 시키는 일들은 아직은 피지컬 AI가 완전히 활성화가 안 됐기 때문에
지금은 컴퓨터 안에서 일어나는 일들을 주로 한다 라고 보시면 되는데
에이전틱 AI 생각을 해 보시면
결국에 나 대신에 AI가 컴퓨터 갖고 일을 하는 거니까
그럼 이 컴퓨터 자체에서 봤을 때도
이 컴퓨터가 할 일이 많아질까 적어질까 라고 생각을 해 봤을 때는
많아질 수밖에 없는 거죠
AI가 이제 내 컴퓨터를 알아서 다루니까
원래는 귀찮아서 안 했을 작업들도 자꾸 AI한테 자꾸 시키는 거죠
그러다 보니까 전통적인 컴퓨터 작업에 대한 수요가 늘어나고 있다
이렇게 볼 수가 있을 것 같아요
그럼 그 전통적인 컴퓨터가 하던 일을 하는 것들이 CPU니까
CPU의 수요가 늘어나고 있다
이렇게 연결을 해 볼 수가 있겠죠
그래서 오늘은 시장에서 대세라고 생각하는
인텔의 매력 포인트
그리고 인텔의 리스크 좀 알아볼 건데
일단 가장 최근 실적을 가지고 와 봤습니다
인텔 뭐 대략 이런 느낌이다
이렇게 보시면 될 것 같은데
인텔의 매출은 한
13.6 빌리언?
달러 정도다 라고 보시면 될 것 같은데
한국 돈으로 분기당 매출이 한 20조 원이 조금 안 되고요
이제 그로스마진이라고 해서 매출 총이익률이 한 41% 정도 된다
사실 이렇게 매출 총이익률을 전면에 내세우는 이유는
영업이익률이 인텔이 사실은 매우 낮기 때문이긴 해요
그래서 대략 인텔의 지난 한 5분기 정도의 실적을 봤을 때는
뭐랄까 성장이 딱히 없는 그런 회사로 보입니다
다만 인텔이 그래도
논갭 기준이긴 한데 논갭 논갭
이것까지 알 필요는 없고
어쨌든 간에 인텔의 이익률이 그래도 조금씩은 나아지고 있다
정도로 일단은 설명을 할게요
자 그래서 인텔에 대해서 우리가 알아볼 때는
인텔이라는 회사가 어떤 사업부가 있는지를 좀 알 필요가 있습니다
인텔의 사업부는 굳이 말하자면
이렇게 세 가지로 생각을 하면 될 것 같아요
인텔의 매출 구성과도 일치하는데
인텔의 어떻게 뭘로 돈을 벌고 있느냐
이 세 가지로 돈을 벌고 있습니다
하나
인텔의 지금 당장 캐시카우가 있고요
그리고 두 번째
인텔의 미래가 가장 기대되는
지금 가장 시장에서의 기대를 모으는 사업부가 하나가 있고
그 다음에 인텔 입장에서의 복권이 있습니다
이 세 가지 관점에서 얘기를 해 보면
결국에 인텔의 캐시카우는
인텔의 클라이언트 컴퓨팅 그룹이라는 곳인데
이 사업부를 봤을 때는
전통적으로 PC CPU 만들던 그 사업부라고 생각하시면 돼요
여러분들 뭐 다 아시잖아요
동동동동 하면 인텔 인사이드 나오는 거
그런 느낌의 PC나 랩탑이나
랩탑에 가장 그 두뇌에 해당하는 CPU를 만드는
바로 그 사업부라고 볼 수가 있겠고
그 다음에 데이터 센터 사업부가 있죠
이 데이터 센터 N AI 사업부가 서버용 CPU를 만듭니다
요게 이제 최근에 기대를 많이 받고 있는 거고
네트워킹 앤 엣지는 넘어가도 되고요
그 다음에 인텔의 제가 복권이라고 얘기하는 게
인텔 파운드리입니다
자 파운드리가 뭔가요
고객이 설계를 해 오면
그 설계한 걸 기반으로 해서
실제 제조 생산을 하는 거
반도체
제조 생산을 하는 그런 업을 파운드리라고 하고
이 파운드리의 대장은 누구다
TSMC입니다
참고로 한국에선 삼성전자가 또 이거를 잘하고 있죠
그래서 기대를 얻고 있는데
인텔도 요거를 하고 있다
이렇게 보시면 되는데
자 인텔 파운드리의 특이한 부분은 뭐냐면요
인텔 파운드리의 매출 중에서
외부 고객의 매출 비율이 거의 없어요
네 거의 없습니다
이거 5%도 안 될 거 같은데
인텔 파운드리는
현재 매출이 나고 있긴 한데
전부 다 인텔 내부 향 매출입니다
인텔 내부적으로 이거 만들어줘 해서
제조 생산하면서 나오는 매출이지
외부 고객이 맡긴 게 거의 없다라는 게 현 상황이고요
자 그래서 제가 아까도 말씀드린 이 PC 사업
그러니까 클라이언트 앤 컴퓨팅 그룹은
인텔의 최대 매출원이긴 한데
성장률 자체가 거의 안 나오고 있어요
그래서 이런 부분들이 캐시카오이긴 한데
여러분들도 아시다시피 PC 사업이 더 늘어나거나
이런 상황은 아니잖아요
그래서 그런 부분들이 좀 아쉬운 부분인 거고
실제로 지난 5분기 클라이언트 앤 컴퓨팅 그룹의 매출을 봐도
PC 사업은 딱히 뭐 성장은 없다
이렇게 볼 수가 있을 것 같습니다
다만 영업이익률이 상대적으로 좋기 때문에
이걸로 벌어서 다른 사업에 지금 인텔이 쏟아 붓고 있다
이렇게 보시면 되고
그래서 사실 클라이언트 앤 컴퓨팅 그룹 쪽 사업부는
딱히 바뀔 게 없었는데
인텔이 주목을 받기 시작했던 부분은
바로 이 데이터 센터와 AI 관련된 사업부에 있는데요
성장률이 상당히 좋아요
그래서 22%
전년 동기 대비해서 22%나 성장을 하고
전체 매출에서도 비중이 적지 않습니다
거의 40%에 가까워요
그러니까 그런 게 22%나 성장을 하고 있다는 거 자체가 좋은 거고
쉽게 말하면 서버에 들어가는 CPU를 파는 겁니다
데이터 센터에 들어가야 하는 CPU를 팔고 있는 거고요
그래서 보시면 살짝 보셔도
아 이건 그래도 좀 우상향하고 있구나
이런 느낌이 좀 들지 않습니까
지난 5개 분기를 보셔도
그래서 꾸준히 이렇게 한 20-30%의 성장을 하고 있고
그리고 또 사실 이익도 꽤 잘 나요
그래서 요거가 매력이 있다 라고 볼 수가 있고
심지어 최근에 구글과 LTE라고 해서
장기 공급 계약을 또 맺었습니다
그래도 이 데이터 센터에 실제로 많이 CPU가 필요한가 보다
왜냐면 CPU가 필요하니까
구글이랑 이렇게 장기 공급 계약도 맺는 거겠구나
이런 생각을 우리가 할 수가 있는 거겠죠
자 근데 이제 인텔의 복권
인텔의 한방은 사실 파운드리에 있다라고 볼 수도 있는 거 같아요
왜냐면 인텔의 파운드리 부문이 여러 가지로 참 아리디드하고
엄청 잘 될 수도 있을 것 같고
아니면 진짜 힘들 수도 있을 것 같아요
지금 인텔의 파운드리 실적인데
대충 보셔도 매출이 한 4-5밀리언 정도
한국 돈으로 7조 원, 8조 원 정도 매출이 나오고 있는 거
요거 자체는 괜찮은데 손실이 상당히 많이 나고 있어요
그래서 이 부문의 영업이익률이 마이너스 45%입니다
물론 이 마이너스 45%도 그 전풍기 생각하면
그 전풍기가 마이너스 55%였거든요
그러니까 그 전풍기에 비해서는 이제 손실률이 낮아지긴 했는데
이익성이 좋아지긴 했는데
아직도 절대적인 숫자 자체가 마이너스 45%다 라는 거
근데 요게 되게 양면적인 거 같긴 해요
그러니까 컵에 물이 반 잔이 들었을 때
이 반 잔이 있는 물을 보고
야 물이 반 밖에 없네 라고 생각할 거냐
아니면 물이 무려 반이나 있다 라고 생각할 거냐인 것처럼
인텔도 이거 얼핏 보면
야 인텔 엄청 영업이익률이 마이너스 45%였는데
마이너스 45%니까
좀만 더 하면은 영업이익률 막 TSMC처럼
영업이익률 막 20% 30% 이렇게 올리면은
야 인텔은 큰 이익이 영업이익이 올라갈 여지가
정말 높은 거 같다 라고도 볼 수가 있는 거예요
어쨌든 간에 지난 한 3, 4분기 정도 생각해 보면
인텔이 파운드리 쪽에 이 적자 폭을 줄여 나가고 있는 건 사실이거든요
그래서 요 부분이 상당히 기대를 모으고 있다 라고 볼 수가 있겠고요
자 그리고 인텔이 계속 얘기하는 게
파운드리 쪽의 수요률도 많이 이렇게 개선이 됐는데
특히나 18옴 스트롱 14옴 스트롱 이 공정이 아주 미세한 공정인데
요 아주 초미세 공정에 수요률이 개선이 된 게 큰 영향을 주었다 라고 합니다
최근에 파운드리 쪽에 있었던 가장 핫한 뉴스 중의 하나는
바로 애플이 자체 프로세서 생산을 앞두고
인텔과 초기 협상을 진행했다 라는 뉴스였습니다
전통적으로 애플은
대부분 TSMC에 맡겼거든요
그런데 요즘에 TSMC가 너무 잘 돼
TSMC가 애플 칩만 만들겠습니까
전 세계의 모든 첨단 GPU CPU는 다 TSMC를 통해서밖에 만들 수가 없거든요
그러니까 전 세계가 다 TSMC에게 줄을 서다 보니까
애플 입장에서도 야 이거 공급원을 다변화 하지 않으면 리스크가 있겠다라는 생각을 한 거죠
그러다 보니까 자연스럽게 그 다음 티어라고 할 수 있는 회사들로 알아본 거야
그래서 애플이 최근에 삼성전자를
인텔과 논의를 진행하고 있다라는 얘기가 있습니다
그리고 파운드리 쪽에서는 인텔과 테슬라가 파운드리 협력을 한 게 매우 인상적이었죠
엄밀히 따지면 XAI까지도 껴줘야 되는 것 같은데
어쨌든 간에 테슬라가 2021년 테슬라 가장 최근 실적 발표에서
인텔의 14옴 스트롱 공정으로 테라펩의 AI 칩을 만들 것이다 라고 발표를 했습니다
이렇게 또 일론 머스크의 파트너가 인텔과 테슬라의 AI 칩을 만들 것이다 라고 발표를 했습니다
이렇게 또 일론 머스크의 파트너가 인텔과 테슬라의 AI 칩을 만들 것이다 라는 것 자체가
인텔 입장에서는 상당한 큰 기대를 얻을 수가 있는 거죠
특히나 이게 정말 잘 만들어진다 라고 하면
일론 머스크 입장에서는 엄청난 반도체들을 팔아먹을 곳은 너무 많잖아요
기존의 스페이스X와 XAI 그리고 테슬라에 얼마나 많은 반도체가 필요하겠습니까
그런 관점에서는 또 인텔이 엄청난 우군을 끼고 있다
일론 머스크라는 엄청나게 큰 인물과 콜라보레이션을 한다는 것 자체는
시장에서 매우 큰 기대를 모을 수밖에 없습니다
테라팹이 어떻게 진행될지가 아직 완전히 구체화된 건 아니긴 한데
어쨌든 간에 매우 매우 기대가 된다 라고 이렇게 볼 수가 있겠고요
그래서 인텔의 기대되는 점을 좀 간단히 정리를 해보면
CPU 시장의 성장은 매우 분명해 보입니다
특히 데이터 센터 쪽의 CPU 시장의 성장은
저도 이 에이전틱 AI를 사용하는 입장에서는 상당히 좀 든든하다 이런 생각이 좀 들고요
그리고 CPU 쪽은 이게 사실 장점이자 단점이기도 하고
최근에 이제 ARM 주가가 떨어졌던 시장에서
이런 이유기도 한데
어차피 당분간은 CPU 만들 거면 다 TSMC가 만들어야 되거든요
그러니까 최첨단 CPU는 전부 다 TSMC가 제조 생산을 하는 상황인데
아시겠지만 TSMC가 캡파를 올리기가 너무 힘들어요
TSMC가 지금 고객이 많아서 공장을 더 돌리고 싶은데
공장을 더 돌리고 싶어도 이거 물리적으로 공장의 규모를 크게 만드는 게 한계가 있다 보니까
CPU가 당분간 생산량 그러니까 Q가 많이 늘어나기는 어렵습니다
CPU의 생산량은 늘어나기가 어려운데
오히려 CPU의 생산량은 늘어나기가 어렵습니다
상대적으로 이제 그 가격 P를 올릴 수 있으니까
그런 관점에서 인텔의 CPU가 팍팍팍 공급되지는 못하지만
아이러니하게는 이것이 CPU 상승 사이클을 더 길게 만들 수도 있지 않나
이런 생각이 좀 들고요
그리고 제가 아까도 말씀드렸지만
파운드리가 안 긁은 복권 같은 존재인데
지금 결국에 인텔이 벌고 있는 돈 다 결국 파운드리에 때려 박고 있는 거거든요
근데 이 파운드리가 만약에 잘 된다라고 하면
진짜 지금 시가총액은 우수울 때인데
10억 정도의 회사가 될 수도 있습니다
이거 너무 과장일 수 있는데
엔비디아 더하기 TSMC만큼의 회사가 되는 거 아니냐
뭐 이런 꿈도 한번 그려볼 수가 있는 거겠죠
거기에 또 기대가 되는 부분은
미국 정부가 투자를 했다라는 겁니다
근데 미국 정부가 투자했을 때
지금 인텔 주가의 5분의 1의 가격에 투자했다라는 거
그게 이제 충격적인 얘기긴 한데
어쨌든 미국 정부라는 뒷배가 있다
그럼 어떻게든 미국 정부가 잘 되게 만들겠지
이런 부분을 생각을 할 수가 있는 거 같고요
또 인텔의 CEO가 될 수 있는 것 같고요
리프탄이라고 있습니다
인텔의 CEO 리프탄이 그래도 좀 기대를 모으는 것 중에 하나가
엔지니어 출신인 것도 대단하고
원래 난양대학교와 MIT에서 박사까지 하신 그런 분인데
반도체 설계 소프트웨어 회사인 케이던스에서 CEO로 재직을 하면서
이분이 거의 십 몇 년 동안 있었던 거 같은데
주가를 3,200%나 올렸습니다
물론 반도체 업황 자체가 좋았다라고 볼 수도 있겠지만
어쨌든 그런 경쟁에서 뒤처지지 않고 했다라는 거
매우 좋아 보이고
엔지니어 출신인 것도 좋았고
그리고 인텔은 완전 하드웨어 회사인데
단지 아쉽다면
하필이면 좀 소프트웨어 회사니까
반도체를 설계하는 소프트웨어를 만드는 회사라는 점에서
인텔은 완전 그래도 하드웨어 회사인데
여기서의 약간의 뭐랄까 차이?
차이라고 해야 될까요?
약간의 이제 어려움이 있을 수도 있겠다
걱정보다는 솔직히 저는 기대가 더 많다
이렇게 말씀을 드릴 수가 있겠고요
근데 인텔에 걱정되는 점이 없는 게 아니에요
뭐가 걱정이 되냐면
CPU 시장에 만약에
이 AI빨 성장이
하고 하면
이거 인텔의 투자의 가장 큰 아이디어 중에
하나가 깨지는 겁니다
그래서 그게 일단은 가장
이게 일단 첫 번째 걱정이라고 볼 수가 있는데
다만 저는 이게 그렇게 저한테는
큰 걱정은 아닌 거 같고요
두 번째랑 세 번째는 조금 더 실체적인 걱정인데
두 번째 걱정은 바로 AMD입니다
왜 AMD가 걱정이 되냐
AMD랑 직접적으로 CPU 시장에서 경쟁을 하고 있기 때문인데
얼핏 보시면 이런 그림을 우리가 그려볼 수가 있습니다
인텔의 매출 그리고
AMD의 매출인데
보시면 아시겠지만
인텔의 매출 점점 내려가고
AMD의 매출은 점점 올라가고 있어요
다시 말해서 이 시장 점유율
인텔의 시장 점유율은 점점 줄어들고 있고
AMD의 시장 점유율
ARM의 시장 점유율은 점점 늘어나고 있다라는 겁니다
그러니까 파이 전체가 커진다라고 해도
이 시장 점유율을 더 늘리지 못한다는 거는
좀 시장에서는 부정적으로 볼 가능성이 높다
이런 생각이 들고요
자 그리고 가장 또 마지막으로의 걱정은 바로 파운드입니다.
파운드리 수율인 것 같아요
제조 생산을 직접 인텔이 하는데
이거를 무난하게 잘 할 것인가
이거를 무난하게 잘 하면
사실 인텔은 지금보다 훨씬 더 비싼
최소 1 trillion 간다고 봅니다
근데 파운드리 수율이 안 좋게 나오면
그러면 인텔의 주가 다시 태초마을로 돌아갈 수가 있겠고요
이게 왜 이런 얘기를 하냐면
인텔을 오랫동안 지켜보신 분들은 다 알 거야
10nm를 하면서 인텔이 진짜 엄청나게 고생을 몇 년 동안 했습니다
수율이 안 나왔거든요
그러니까 미국 회사들은
안 되는구나 이런 얘기가 나오는 거야
그래서 제가 예전에 TSMC 관련된 자료를 보다가
봤던 기사에서 나온 얘기인데
대만의 TSMC는 왜 이렇게 제조 생산을 잘 하냐
라고 할 때는
TSMC 공장에서는 새벽 1시에 문제가 생기면
새벽 2시에 문제가 해결된다 라고 하더라고요
그런데 일반적인 미국 공장에서는
새벽 1시에 문제가 생기면
다음 날에 문제가 해결이 된다는 거예요
이런 것들이 바로 수율의 차이를 만들어 내는 거죠
그러니까 대만은 TSMC라는 기업 자체가
이 직원들도 다 그렇게 생각하는데
TSMC라는 회사에 다니는 것 자체가 너무 영광이어서
워라벨도 없고 그냥 TSMC를 위해서 직원들이 다 희생하는 거야
제조 생산 라인에 있는 직원들조차
그런데 약간 미국이란 나라는 좀 다르잖아 분위기가
여러분들도 아시다시피 이 버거 형들은 약간 그런 건 아니야
나의 워라벨도 중요하고
아무리 회사가 위에서 까라고 해도
야 내가 쉬어야 되면 쉬는 거고
내가 일하고 싶으면 일하는 거고
어떻게 새벽에 사람을 불러내냐
이런 마인드가 있는 곳들이 미국과 미국이니까
공장이다 보니까 지금까지 미국에서 파운드리 회사들이
그렇게 성공적이지 못했고
순수한 미국 계열의 파운드리 회사들
제조 생산하는 회사들이 그렇게 성공적이지 못했는데
과연 그런 부분들을 성공할 것이냐
인텔은 성공할 것인지가 매우 귀추가 주목되는 부분이고
다만 저번 분기와 이번 분기를 봐서는
조금 더 성공을 하고 있는 방향으로 가고 있는 것 같은데
과연 어떻게 될지를 좀 봐야 되는데
뭐 이런 게 있는지는 모르겠는데
인텔의 공장 근처에 피자집이 있는데
피자집이 좀 잘 되고 있는지
뭐 이런 거 좀 체크해야 되나?
뭐 이런 생각이 들더라고요
그래서 야근 열심히 하는지
이런 거를 좀 봐야 되지 않나
매일매일 카메라로 이렇게 찍어야 되나?
불빛이 좀 켜져 있나 안 켜져 있나
이런 생각이 들었고요
그래서 이렇게 오늘 인텔 좀 찍먹을 해 봤습니다
단기적으로는 오히려 너무 좀 주가가 오른 부분도 있어 가지고
단기적으로 쉬어 갈 수도 있을 것 같은데
그래도 새로운 대장주가 될 수 있는
그런 자격을 갖고 있는 회사 중에 하나가 아닌가
라는 생각을 좀 들긴 합니다
제가 이렇게 좀 찍먹을 해 봤는데
혹시나 또 다른 기업들
좀 제가 분석했으면 찍먹했으면 하는 기업들이 있으면
댓글로 알려 주시면 제가 한번 보고 이해가 가고
컨텐츠 해도 재밌겠다 싶으면
또 그런 회사를 좀 다뤄 보도록 하겠습니다
그럼 저는 또 다음 영상으로 돌아오도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다